dude I remember when I was young man
being young boy mom's coming home you
would hear that dude you would be I'd be
knee deep we would be making mud and the
tub we used to bring soil in from
outside rare soil or just even regular
soil and we were bringing in from
outside and get it in get it in two
hours worked the soil you know when we
soiled up you know what I'm saying we're
ready with it we got the dam of them you
know we got two foot by four foot of the
dam Mississippi Delta sitting right
there in the bathtub and we cut that
water on bra make our own just mud and
we'd be just making mud cakes mud pies
and my sister she made like a dang you
know a couple layer mud cake with the
with the boot with the fondant with that
fondant icing I'm like damn what are you
doing this is just mud we're we can't
eat this and she were right happy uh
happy Anniversary Henry in and I'm like
who the [ __ ] is Henry you're four years
old what are you doing around this
neighborhood but we had some times man
but then once you heard one kid somehow
would find out they would get a thing in
their head they would see the clock or
whatever oh [ __ ] it's almost 5:00 p.m.
that's when mom gets off work and that
means it takes mom nine minutes unless
she stopped to have a little cigarette
then it take her 13 minutes to get home
because sometime mom pull over behind
the bank and hit that freaking you know
get that little Winston in her get that
chirp-chirp
get that up or you know that that light
up or that's gonna help her you know
come home and not you know whip the kids
ass immediately she will hear the
children first and and man mom would
come home and we'd be like [ __ ] man we
gotta get rid of this mud cuz now you
got before it was soil but now you added
that water now it's heavy mud the [ __ ]
is alluvial you got a dam
you got us a baby palm popping up over
here you got an arborist beating on the
door you know trying to get a deal and
so now we got to throw all of this mud
out the window what we didn't realize
was mom she parks right out by the
window right we weren't thinking you
know we're logistical e we weren't
really there because we were just
children so we're just sitting there
throwing mud out the window brush sand
mud it all kind of just toys in it it
had a bottle of uh that suave hair
conditioner remember that [ __ ] with the
pineapple on it dude I'd leave the house
smelling [ __ ] Polynesian I'd have
bees coming over a couple of urban
chicks showing up what are you doing you
know when you had that that suave
conditioner that pineapple fresh and
that [ __ ] would leave you sent it up but
now the mud has everything she throwing
all kind of [ __ ] out you know Daniel
snuck over there he's been over there
doing something you know writing dirty
words in the mud and he got stuck in it
and he [ __ ] went out the window he's
airborne
you know Daniel bro you know he makes
his own choices but they're not good and
so man I remember their mom would come
inside and be or as bro and I don't
blame her I don't blame her you have you
paying 170 dollars a month for rent in a
three-bedroom and these kids [ __ ]
brought about 50 pounds of [ __ ] mud
up into the tub dude because then what
happened after that it went into the
pipes then we couldn't use the toilet
upstairs then everybody had to use the
toilet downstairs and the toilet
downstairs right by the dinner table so
you'd have you know some fancy
Fauntleroy wants to slip off from from
dinner you know mom's grilling up a
couple hot cakes or whatever you know
maybe a couple slices of bacon you know
a couple lean pieces and then some fancy
[ __ ] own he gets a little feel a
little quake in his in his gurney in his
girder and
his belly and he wants to slide off to
the side and use the tallit and did it
was just we [ __ ] ruin mom's life but
dang she kept on with us she kept on
with us man well thanks for watching
that video right there that was a
beautiful little segment I think but of
course i'm partisan to myself but you
can move on to another video right now
you can check on this video or on this
video that's two different options and
you can also subscribe to the channel
check on a new video subscribe to the
channel check subscribe subscribe